-One of the ways that you have
spoken about paying
for this bill is, of course,
taxing billionaires more.
-Yes.
-Are you worried --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bear with me here.
Are you worried,
if you tax them too much,
they will stop going to space?
[ Laughter ]
-You know, it is something
that I've never even once
worried about.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, okay.
-I can't even make up
a good lie about that.
Are you kidding me?
I mean, for these guys
to shoot off into space,
people who are paying
less in taxes -- right? --
than public schoolteachers,
than firefighters,
than folks who are working hard
every day,
and then to say, "Thank y'all,
because the way
I was able to do this
was by not paying taxes,"
I mean, could we be more overt
about what is broken
in this country?
-It does strike me...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...it is very overt.
It's not much --
They make it real --
-This is, like, not subtle.
-No, it's true.
-This is like when --
a cowboy hat on Lex Luthor.
-Here's how not-subtle it is.
They count it down.
They want you to see it so bad,
they count it down.
-Exactly.
-They're like, "10! 9!"
They're like, "Look!"
-Right, right, right, uh-huh.
-This is very exciting.
You wrote a book.
-I did.
-You have, obviously --
You've written books
for adults.
-Yeah.
-And I'm curious,
is it just a super breeze
when you're writing for kids?
Be honest.
-It's just different.
-Yeah. That's a very good --
I mean, again, these kids,
they can't vote.
You can...
[ Laughter ]
...say what you want about them.
They can't vote.
-No, no.
It's just different.
I actually -- since I'd never
written a book for children,
I actually took
photocopy paper.
And I knew
what the story line was.
I had the plot down...
-That's good.
...and what I wanted to say,
and so I'd write it
and tape it on pages,
because you need the pages
to turn.
It's got to be
a real page-turner, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And it was fun, and I loved it.
I wrote this because I did it
about a zillion thousand
pinkie promises
with little girls and
big girls and senior girls
and brothers and daddies
and dogs.
[ Laughter ]
-This, we should note --
all pre-COVID, right?
-All pre-COVID.
-If you came at me
with a pinkie right now,
I would...
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
But I really wanted
to think about
what all those pinkie promises
were about.
And I wrote this --
You know, I ran for president
and I lost.
And I wrote this
right after that,
because I really wanted
to say,
the most important thing is,
girls hear a lot
about what they can't do.
Sometimes it's said out loud.
Most of the time anymore,
it's said quietly, but there.
And what I really wanted to do
is say, "What matters is.
you get in the fight."
Yeah, I ran for president.
I lost.
But ask me how sorry I am
that I ran.
Not one bit, not one bit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that's what this is about.
-I, um...
-It's true.
-So, I want to play
a little quiz with you,
see how well you know
your own writing.
-Okay.
[ Light laughter ]
-I'm gonna read lines
from your writing.
It's either gonna be
some lines from the book...
-This book?
-This book.
-"Pinkie Promises."
-...or some of your
academic writings on bankruptcy.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Don't make this too hard.
And I just have to pick?
-You just have to say,
"That's from 'Pinkie Promises,"
or, "That's from
my bankruptcy writing."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Okay, I'm ready.
-"For every party helped
by recognition of a claim
that a debtor would have delayed
long enough under state law
to escape payment entirely,
and for every noncontract claim,
it was able to collect
a pro rata share
that would have been otherwise
practically impossible
to collect,
there is some other party
who lost the benefits
enjoyed in the hierarchical
system of state law."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Like, I'm really embarrassed.
That came from my
not-"Pinkie Promises" writing.
-That's right.
-Okay.
-Do you want to try one more?
-Oh, yeah. Sure.
[ Light laughter ]
-"Monday was Polly's
first day at a new school."
[ Laughter ]
[ cheers and applause ]
Even I knew that one.
Oh, no, no, no.
Did you get tested?
Did you pass?
-I did.
-Okay, I'll do one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Senator Elizabeth Warren,
everybody!
"Pinkie promises"
is available now.